[Music]
hey what's up it's bill per Jesus Christ
at my pasty it's the [ __ ] overhead
lighting there um so what you're about
to watch is the live not live recorded
live video that we did at the Troubadour
had a great time when I was down there
gonna try to raise some money for that
wonderful venue just the little heads up
the audio kind of sucks in some places
it's the first time we ever recorded
down there had a little issue with my
whatever the [ __ ] he called a recording
device and there's an AC going on and
off in the background so apologies to
that but I think Andrew familis was able
to do his editing magic and I think
everything will be alright hopefully but
thank you for watching we'll have an
autographed poster if you want to buy to
help contribute we'll have a donation
button I think on the troubadours
website and everything but uh this is a
special one because I love this venue
and it's done so much for so many people
so I hope you enjoy the podcast alright
thank you Hey so no ice no bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 29
know it I mean it always flies by when
you got to walk around with the product
any Daniel faith did you [ __ ] seems to
go by so much quicker shout out to
everybody still going to the beach yeah
[ __ ] all that fake news with this spike
spiders whatever they know [ __ ]
scientists you know a bunch of eggheads
think about all the smart people in high
school you didn't like that did you
they never went to the beach they've
learnt the cool people huh [ __ ] it in
the sand that was you why would you
listen to him now what what is they one
of the spelling bee
it's an this is an American man if you
want to go to the [ __ ] beach you go
to the [ __ ] beach alright you don't
have to wear a mask you're an American
Jesus Christ it's an embarrassment what
we're doing right now it's like the
world SATs and we're getting the [ __ ]
lowest score and I would love to just
blame the four wheelers you know the
people on their [ __ ] ranches the Red
Sticks
that's who usually
we are doing this show it gets you
forgot a mess all these masks chitchat
ah that went viral who got hit his car
realized he forgot his mask who forgot
his mat real I realized that I forgot my
mask within half a mile of my house did
I turn around did I go back I think of
my fellow American or that I think how
difficult it was going to be to make a
three-point turn with power steering
power brakes and a reverse camera
reverse backup camera whatever you call
it I said [ __ ] I'm gonna keep going
to have a mask for me down here they
probably have an 8-ball in the mask to
make sure that a good show fortunate
show them on the last podcast I was
going to
it was so weird am I supposed to be
playing to the camera I don't even know
if it's like no crowded this is not how
I envisioned never be nice to couch
[Music]
very male I don't want to get that off
Jesus Christ the way people are all
attacking each other on the internet
does it make you feel better okay
Cameron okay Brad okay Chad okay boomer
you socialist you [ __ ] apologist geez
everybody acted like they're on a
[ __ ] playground and they're like oh
let's not even record in anger what
happened we recorded anywhere else I
thought this thing supposed to be
recorded I can't even [ __ ] it record
right well we got some of that yeah
everybody else is so much better with uh
pieces I enjoyed this to put your feet
up so I'm at the world-famous
troubadour everyone from Joan Baez
Jackson Browne Albert Einstein did it
set here before you realized he wasn't a
musician you realized it he got booed
offstage and he was like I'm such a
[ __ ] idiot and then there was a
groupie consensual groupie right it's
going well I think your mustache is cute
maybe there's something else you're good
at means like well it was always pretty
good with my erector set and next thing
you know this man helped to end World
War two by coming up with the device
that kills all the birds the babies
right up to the bad guys and it needed
to be done according to world history
you know did you need to give them
dessert with the entree I don't know
I'll tell anybody out there right now
about America anybody can drop one you
drop the second one okay that's that's
when the statement is made okay I think
that's why we've never been invaded
since have you ever been invaded I don't
think we ever had have we ever been in
vain let's let's go through the rolodex
here all right the first one was the
Revolutionary War which I'm reminded of
because I'm watching Wheel of Fortune
this week and they're in there in Boston
you know so of course they got to do all
this touristy Boston [ __ ] that no one in
Boston does standing in front of the
paul revere statue the North Church I
saw Pat Sajak throwing a fake [ __ ]
box of tea off his goddamn phone why do
they do that [ __ ] you know what I mean
be funny if they actually did the real
Boston one you know they just cut to a
face [ __ ] streets like the alley next
to a bar down near the dam anyway so
thank you guys for listening to this
podcast now if you are a fan of live
music yeah this thing keeps shutting off
dude I don't know what's going on here
keep shutting off so we're gonna have
the recording why would it do that was
it full it's the desert Snapple
it's not malicious it appears to be when
it shuts yeah it only goes on for a few
seconds and then shuts up this is
exciting this is the kind of excitement
that raises money listening to the holy
person on the show fiddle with his
devices alright I hope you guys are
gonna get this right what is that what
is that that is a zoom audio recorder
zoom audio recording that was like a
playboy picture from the 70s can I can I
use this as a microphone you meant I can
bring this up never seems fine yep not
too close welcome everybody all but
David Lee Roth here huh oh my god hi
everybody I'm in West Hollywood with the
bedazzled microphone and we're gonna do
this [ __ ] yeah Pat Sajak I love The
Wheel of Fortune win a fortune makes you
feel smart jeopardy makes you feel
stupid will poor fortune is the tightest
[ __ ] show ever anytime there's any
sort of money involves art anytime
there's any sort of money involved they
have like the [ __ ] like the last
prize of the game they'll do [ __ ] would
it be like this is an activity you guess
like five letters and then the person
never gets it and then like that's this
the puzzle like the solution the
activity is like sewing my buttons on my
jacket I just sit at home yelling at the
TV like that's not a [ __ ] activity
I'd like to solve the puzzle frosting
Spock faucet in January that in a bit
but you get the grandfather clock anyway
so what we're doing here is we're trying
to raise money here because a lot of
Weatherly's smaller places
struggling here so we're going to have I
have a poster that's being made I'm
going to autograph the thing or not
making sure everybody has a choice every
time everything is above board
I don't want to mansplain or anything of
that nature
I'll be honest with you I'm so [ __ ]
saying this together they've got a damn
house and I'm so excited come down here
see this legendary venue and do a set
and have a good time but I got to tell
you something don't be lack of hearing
any sound other than whatever that
refrigeration sound is that the sound of
an air conditioner I have no idea what
it is it's kind of like a lonely thing
you know that's not to make it a plumber
but this is the place when I come back
and I shake the rust off alright when
old Billy popsicle face he's gonna you
know I was talking to somebody the other
day and they were giving me talk about a
difficult time they were having you this
[ __ ] business you know because
y and z and I was just like listen dude
I don't want to be an [ __ ]
but I am the color of a [ __ ] popsicle
and I went bald okay it took me 28 years
to get any acting work in this [ __ ]
business alright I would love to sit
here and listen to your [ __ ] moaning
and [ __ ] complaining but I don't have
anything for you I'm gonna go or shut up
you know my big question right now is
when I go home is the sound of that
refrigeration just going to be in my
[ __ ] head
but what if anybody's been done it had
bombs so [ __ ] bad that they actually
heard that this sound in front of a full
[ __ ] audience anywhere plotting ahead
so we're gonna have an autographed
poster here and outside the thing and
all the money aside from the money used
to ship the thing out it's going to go
towards sentence of money so this great
venue should stay open
when there's no [ __ ] pulpit fingers
over I just don't want it to be a bunch
of Walmart's and Costco's it's beginning
Freddie's you know the big boys on the
goddamn Street you know you know what is
cool I like down the street and I was
nervous that that busybody place was
going to go out of business that's a mom
I think place that sells exercise
equipment that I'm like wait a minute
that that store is surrounded by gay
guys who all appear to be shredded you
know so you all the row is going to be
getting the latest thing to keep
themselves ready that's another tough
thing about being a gay guy this aside
from all of the homophobia is you the
level of shape that you have to stay in
because you're trying to attract a guy
it's actually a great thing because
you'll stay in wonderful shape I wonder
if there's a movement within the gay
community where they complain about all
the rich guys trade them in for younger
gay guys does that has anything that's
got anything I haven't done any research
I'll just say it with confidence and
then suddenly it will become a thing
anyway let's let's do some home
homefront updates here I have been I
don't know what I've been doing every
day I come on the stupid podcast and I
tried it like
[ __ ] to talk about because I'm just
staying at home I basically living like
Groundhog Day
aside from the fact that this not
another person in our house who by the
way is absolutely crushing tummy tuck
crushing tummy time I got to tell you
like I'm doing all that cliche dad stuff
you know anything he doesn't lift his
head up with his feet also you know
while he's on his stomach strong his
back is he's gonna be an Olympian I was
talking to the other day telling I'm
going to teach him how to fly a
helicopter
notice how they could be whatever he
wanted and at one point I said he could
be an astronaut and then I just realized
what an old dad I was that's not a
really lucrative you know I'll tell you
a bit of like just sits around for
[ __ ] ever it's got to be an accident
a real [ __ ] job anymore and they
changed the name of it I just like that
there wasn't like man wasn't in it so
they didn't have to change it you know
like if it was astronaut man astronaut
person which would be a typical female
thing you know after all the monkeys die
and the guys get in it they [ __ ] go
in and get their [ __ ] asses kicked
about us now that we know it's sort of
safe do I have any sort of my [ __ ]
password here internet password
yes how do I get everybody I'll just get
on my phone cuz I don't
yell it out what is it Axel's late at 95
oh right and on right-handers I'm a
really gonna do that I [ __ ] love that
Soros it means late as much as he wants
according to him it wasn't his fault
you probably wait for the Sun to go down
so it would get a sunburn that's what
happened who's ever going to astronaut
astronaut training see it's probably a
[ __ ] open mic I could go to down the
street let's see how you look at an
orange jumpsuit first launch space
astronaut education astronaut in
training NASA this is 2004 it
immediately goes to some that is a
lizard this job doesn't exist anymore
didn't that dudes from [ __ ] insync
want to be an astronaut that's one of
the dangers of being in a point man you
know that super successful you could
just never recapture those height
together to the point that you're
actually willing to get into subject and
you want to go to Mars some point that
has to happen you know if we can never
stop out this Kobe I think that
that that weirdo kind of mix the really
fast cars his name isn't Tesla the guy
with the laminated face Elon Musk Elon
Musk that guy should make that thing and
what you do is you get a bunch of people
who refuse to wear masks right and then
you just stick them on it you say you
send them out to Mars there you go it
doesn't have to go to Mars it really
only has to go 100 feet in the air and
then you just shut off the thrusters you
just let it fall right it saves you wait
a minute I think I'm on to something
then that would save you all this
[ __ ] money while trying to kill all
of these people because I think that
that's what I've learned in this during
this whole pandemic is if there's a
virus out there killing people and then
we need to kill the virus or let it die
off and then we also need to kill the
people that are not respecting that you
you can kill others right is that how it
works that is the loudest what is that
[ __ ] was it the lights it's got to be
the lights I don't know what
that humming sound of the lights the
cancerous lights that I'm sitting on
Rebecca Internet you are not connected
fine fine
oh did you see Woodrow Wilson that's in
the news what Rob Wilson at Princeton
University is saying we don't want this
this guy like I think they gave the
cafeteria after the Woodrow Wilson
[ __ ] cafeteria in juice bar they
named it after him and everybody say the
guy was was unknowing sit on this racist
[ __ ] when he was president or something
like the only racist ideas which is
crazy because he was a white guy born in
the 1800s like I can't believe he would
say a bunch of crazy [ __ ] like that so I
look it up and I see all the stuff that
he said pretty standard pretty standard
hateful [ __ ] then he said then I just
kept scrolling going by the obvious
racist [ __ ] just kept scrolling and just
kept rolling and waiting to find what I
wanted I wanted to find my plaintiff
Cameron after those are you listening at
home I wanted to find what I wanted to
find on that [ __ ] thing I wanted to
see where his ways to [ __ ] about look we
can't slow them over over the standard
white guy race to [ __ ] that he said a
hundred years ago what about the Federal
Reserve Act then oppress dog people
his hatred was just with one segment
whose [ __ ] federal reserve's a minute
that touches all of us there you go so
what we're gonna do
we're gonna take his name off the
cafeteria
all right we're gonna do that but we're
not going to address what the [ __ ] he
did even did you write a letter Woodrow
Wilson's letter of regret after he died
he's like God Jesus you know I am
[ __ ] I should have done that I think
everybody was away on my Christmas Eve
or some [ __ ] that's the way it's told
and then you know that was like nine
people there we're all promised what can
you give somebody back then the first
motorcycle with white tires will give
you give me that the [ __ ] a horse and
I don't know a bale of cotton what the
[ __ ] would you put would but was a gift
back there okay yeah they itch eat wolf
soup and a team of horses if you put
this [ __ ] thing and that's fine
I can't say I don't try not to comment
on comic [ __ ] trash
but I don't want to do a show right now
I don't have to show it to tell this
[ __ ] is gone the coke it's gone but I
already have a joke if you do a show how
was your show I killed for old people
and one guy with as much I'm kidding
well I'm on stage that'd be a joke here
and by the way people I'm wearing one of
my favorite stand-up shirts I've worn
this thing a lot I think a warning on
Conant this shirt will not [ __ ] quit
this show can take the road okay
unlike a lot of these soft [ __ ]
people out here right now that just
can't [ __ ] handle any sort of breeze
that messes up their bangs this shirt is
old-school tough I'm not saying it
agrees with what bro Wilson I don't mean
that kind of old-school I mean the kind
of old-school toughness that made this
country great that made people get on a
boat they come over here and ignore the
fact that where there was already people
here and claim you discovered it right
talking about that level of toughness
this is the kind of shirt that you could
put measles in and hand to an indigenous
people
we know Diesel's
still kill over by 49 million people a
year and for some reason that doesn't
get any traction all right what else did
I want to talk about a lot of Billy Joel
I don't know what I saw I'm Howard Stern
and he just [ __ ] blew me away you
know when you actually see a true
musician by himself
with just his instrument and he's still
crushing it you know even anything's
gonna suck you know [ __ ]
9:00 in the morning my voice is tired
the guy absolutely totally good
listening to a bunch of that [ __ ] some
of the stuff you guys suggested to me
that woman it goes by curve eh period a
period our period I don't know what that
stands for forgive me I bet if you was a
guy you'd know exactly what it stood for
but listening to that little new Lamb of
God which has Park Chris Adler on it in
part the new trauma whoever that is
really enjoyed that album another than
that I'm not doing [ __ ] you know what
I'm doing I'm [ __ ] laying around and
I haven't laid out for the rest of this
[ __ ] I'm laying around in my [ __ ]
house and I am waiting for the day when
people will just [ __ ] stay inside and
stop breathing on each other you know
oh man I was going to suggest this
[ __ ] thing I don't think it's a good
idea though I was going to say that no
you know what I'm just gonna I'm
predicting something from a laying down
position I don't know if you guys know
this if you ever want to have a great
idea Mike you need to be laying down
think about how many times have you laid
down and you thought about leaving your
girlfriend she's laying next to you
she's snoring and you're like I have to
get out of this [ __ ] relationship
when you're across from her in a
restaurant back in the day you know
you're eating food there's other broads
to look at you don't give a [ __ ] but
when you're laying them and all you can
hear is the sound of the rock star
lights humming over your head that's
when you are the most clear I'm gonna
say that mass shaming at some point is
gonna on I can't say I'm gonna say what
it was going to escalate to but I just
think that it would probably can you
please keep six feet away from me please
to meet without a mask its [ __ ] why does
the world have to be so sensitive
isn't it enough that I have a fuzzy
microphone this is a chinchilla that I'd
be headed before I did this actually a
baboon ate it alive when a bad birds
gonna get me - for [ __ ] eating things
alive
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like how fresh
does the meat have to be you can't just
snap the [ __ ] thing's neck whenever I
see them do that [ __ ] III agree with
Rogan where Roman says that you know how
you know let me did that hope it that
we're monkeys you know I always love
that bit and then I watched a monkey
enjoy eating another thing alive and I
was just like yeah that's human behavior
getting off on the suffering the
suffering [ __ ] succotash and you guys
you guys are great dad like me I'm gonna
blow my own [ __ ] horn right here
alright consensually I was I this
morning I made my daughter in my hat
I made it what's known as a Dutch baby I
call it a Dutch baby because I don't
want to call it a German pancake because
I'm actually part German and I don't
want anybody to take little snippets of
this and then I'll just send them a line
with Hitler it's actually a German pain
people call it that's baby right but
does that sound make me sound like a
predator I don't know
I made this [ __ ] thing with
blueberries in in a little bit of
powdered sugar
absolutely [ __ ] crushed it got up in
the morning I did my stretches i rehab
my shoulder look at this [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ] huh no pain no pain no pain no
360s I've coming back I'm gonna be doing
my first pull-up by [ __ ] 2022 when
this virus is still going and
everybody's [ __ ] hunting people with
paint guns out here in LA cuz they're
all against guns right playing laser tag
for the last piece of [ __ ] was it
mwah mwah what's the thing when they
force-feed the geese is it foie gras
foie gras foie gras
where is your [ __ ] life at like how
high is your [ __ ] rent that you're
sticking of funnel in a goddamn Medusa's
mouth just shoving food into the [ __ ]
things how do you shake that off how do
you [ __ ] go home
you know you honey what you know she
wants to have a [ __ ] date night oh
you're in an alternative lifestyle they
miss be respectful here are your
boyfriend well they right they want to
watch what was that what was that what
was that [ __ ] show that they had
Transcontinental trans what was it
called transparent I knew they worked it
in there TransAmerican Airlines whatever
right but you don't [ __ ] you go to
sit down with them or they go him or her
to watch your [ __ ] movie how do you
shake that off
you know as he's sitting there next to
you being like I don't feel like you
were into this movie the way I thought
you were gonna be and you got to be like
well you know I mean I was all down to
like [ __ ] up tonight watching this
movie but I mean I force-fed a goose up
I can't get the sound of those flapping
wings out of my head
Jesus Christ we exist I would be proud
of you don't see that bumper sticker
right right next to my mic sons of
[ __ ] my sons are the deeds list
whatever the [ __ ] hate these idiots
say that's always next to some soccer
ball [ __ ] FUNKER sticker my son
force-fed a goose today you know boy we
can't wait to [ __ ] eat that thing in
a month
it started with peasants so that they
could fatten up the liver because they
needed more food out of that one goose
so they started with yes so they front
force-fed it through the funnel so that
they could fatten it up to get enough
goose out of that goose what can they
just shoot a [ __ ] squirrel - you know
there are other things to eat Wow I got
tired useless
[Music]
the older I get the more I play God
I mean our behavior is just inexcusable
and I just really feel like at first
there was just God and then he realized
what he created and then he needed a
skinca it's almost like a script that
didn't have like an antagonist in a
protagonist who is who's who's the bad
guy you had an antagonist project
antagonistic from right before the probe
all those heat up I macro anything for
the peas like cost from [ __ ] prostitute
finally Axl look who finally shows up
what's going on I love like 35 minutes
in 35 minutes in if I told you the
absolute Rockstar that I am now friends
with that just walked into this room and
I don't want to name the name you know
because I don't want you guys to resent
me
I've seen all these feet all these
celebrities they're in this this whole
pandemic they try to say something
positive and all people do is just
concentrate on their impossibly huge
kitchens now a lot of people don't
realize the manager
if you don't know something if you don't
know they don't think they should be
raped my client okay fine you gave me a
shot didn't care that I was the color of
a popsicle digit no you did you're like
you know what I need a challenge
not another way to stick this falling
right into my movie to paint the back of
his head every day before he goes upset
I'm gonna [ __ ] you in I'm gonna make him
a lawyer and that wonderful movie was
called black or white starring Kevin
Costner Octavia Spencer Spencer I'm
sorry Anthony Mackie and stuff I can
only think of one thing at a time all
right
hi we're gonna smoke a cigar that's
right right do you not sit there and
stare at me like you're waiting to [ __ ]
anybody there any one week why don't you
go sit on one of those [ __ ] lungs
over there was that let me puke coming
back in the dare now that's sacrilegious
because you know that bad never kill
whoever was drinking with many that I
know John now John made his debut here
who I recently saw him Las Vegas that
guy is such a beast he had no opener
played for three hours nothing but hits
he didn't play once there wasn't one
bathroom break song I wanted to go to
the bathroom about 90 minutes in and
then he would just [ __ ] Crocodile
Rock can't go now Oh Danielle a lot
brother can't beat now anyways looks
like I was talking
wha-wha for speeding gooses Oh God
needed a scapegoat I think at the
beginning he was talking [ __ ] like yeah
[ __ ] I thought it was going to
take a week and I did it in six days I
got my feet up in seven days what do you
think what it would have gone took eight
days to build this thing what if we just
spent a little more time on human beings
you know so that we wouldn't do [ __ ]
like take us although if you look at all
the other animals out there specifically
the praying mantis and some of these
other women maybe they're just they all
got the devil in I think lions I'm nice
like I might get killed by a praying
mantis or alive I would choose a lion
you know I would want an alligator
because they don't have the ability they
could think after they [ __ ] drowning
and they got to do that that that you
know they clamp on to you and then you
[ __ ] whipped a head around to the like
the other 90% of your body slides off
and then they got like you know your
right ass cheek in their mouth and then
they just they gulp it down it's like
the inch washing
eating
yeah you want to be gonna get murdered
by an animal want to go
one of the cats right now am I still
being recorded you just walked away
and when did you start wearing the hat
backwards when you're filming that's
like a that's a big you look like a
season back now
how far into this bucket again without
any slow 30 bucks 30 minutes in okay
we're off so I should actually do the
advertiser all right where are we
masks chicken intelligence Iowa tell a
friend to [ __ ] off honoring a psycho
this is I'm teasing there's a classic
rock song about Stanley Cup conspiracy
New York Times hat
what am I doing here and I have oh jesus
here we go we got the reeds here you got
the Rex Reed's here alright great Cod
everyone you know whether you're working
from home or working on your fitness
somebody just fell down the stairs
you all right that Mike
there might be careful when you're
walking around up there yeah oh by the
way that's the VIP room yeah I'm just
letting up because I know you've never
been invited up
ah is the rake on earbuds oh [ __ ] look
at these things okay break on whether
you're working from your home or working
on your fitness all right like these
these are sexy men you want to be you
know you want what you're listening to
to be what you're listening to not what
your roommates neighbors significant
other children on all of that [ __ ] of
listening to that's right you want to be
in your own world ignoring your children
and fantasizing that you're Randy Rhoads
this is the product for you everyone
needs to get a great pair of wireless
earbuds oh my god these are great
oh my god can I put this in here it's
it's been [ __ ] vaccinated inoculated
holy [ __ ] do some tremendous and that
was a big nod here but person ice ice I
still like the headphones and I think I
just been converted okay but before you
go dropping hundreds of dollars on a
pair you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from break on absolutely
anything that's not apples you got to be
for it right this is a mom-and-pop
closer Rick want earbuds started and how
about half price of any other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and they
sound just as amazing as other top audio
brands you know this is it right here
the mom-and-pop place is just as good as
the gourmet place we just have to no
errors all right
their newest model the everyday eat 25
each bug
they are the best ones yet with six
hours of playtime that means you get on
a plane in LA fly all the way to [ __ ] in
New York and you're fine it's going to
be a Stewart excuse me there gives me a
nose on duty sir these two piece your
back I was a play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
compact design that keeps you a nice
noise isolated fit and what I love is
they come in this little thing where you
can [ __ ] I like this we're
videotaping this well you tell me I just
get I just get to hear buzz wait a
minute that's not all you also get this
little [ __ ] thing you can stick him
in so you won't lose them beautiful
justice I put tumor a benign tumor one
that can be operated on recons
wireless earbuds are so comfortable and
they are comfy I have one in right now I
don't want to take it out that's [ __ ]
it's mate today's perfect for conference
calls or bring our binging podcast break
on is a game changer you're not getting
these back by the way he seems [ __ ]
rule rape out is a game changer when it
comes to what you expect to pay for high
quality earbuds unlike some of your
other wireless options rake on bought
earbuds are both stylish and discreet
with no dangling wires or stems to
distract anyone during video calls is
that right can you see me stop looking
at this it's pretty stylish I'll check
them out I have him in there
unlike some of your other wireless
options wait I already
that you've heard me you've heard me
talk about how the company was
co-founded by Ray J and celebrities like
Snoop Dogg I did his podcast he's also a
voice on a festive family cardi B
Melissa Etheridge brandy JR Smith we
played for the Knicks right are obsessed
with break ons
pick up a pair and see what the hype is
all about that's the time to get the
latest and greatest from Raycom get 50%
off your order and five red cards on top
/ / that's binary compound cipher for
50% off break on wireless earbuds by
break on comm / / hey we panned around
to show people this this amazing venue
that most people don't ever get to go
into is the plot is the standing room
only up here is the VIP with that dirty
window that I made kitties were pressed
against who knows back in the day back
in the day much fun was had enough
here's where the band that's why they
got the curtains the amount of
billionaires yes best place to see a
show right here like finder says best
place to see you show all right let me
read the next to the next one
I feel like like like I'm running for
president and I never had my notes and
the whole [ __ ] things up campaign
just isn't something happens just what
neva neva ya neva you're it this is the
[ __ ] is that spelled ni ba it stands for
something
neva the troubadour is part of neva the
nash the nation it doesn't be national
the nation independent venue Association
formed at the onset of the Kovach 19
shut down the nationally dependent venue
Association now it's national said issue
first now it has nearly 2,000 members in
all 50 states in Washington DC these are
fully independent concert venues and
show promoters I love these people I
like these people these businesses were
first with the first to close it would
be the last to reopen they are real risk
of closing permanently of Congress what
the [ __ ] let me just set some in my ear
sorry they're at real risk of closing
permanently if Congress does not take
quick in specific action to address the
unique circumstances of this still
shuttered component of the economy yeah
I would say that this is pretty where
they say huh your vital this is going to
be vital for when people come back
essentially essentially sorry here's how
you can help the Troubadour and all the
important independent venues within Niva
NEMA neither please go to WWF our stage
is calm and click on take action to
write your representative and express
your support for niba
hashtag save our stages Niva website is
w
WC are stages calm fire is it time for
the reach is it time for the reads it's
time for advice your host Phil Eber and
I'm ripping up this melody from somebody
else all right like that
that was [ __ ] acapella I think I went
the wrong way and I mixed all of these
up this is like literally me why you're
never on the debating team and I
literally pump all of these up I don't
have them in the right order I'll just
talk about something else shall we yeah
all right all right somebody's writing
in from Montenegro well I was
immediately of has like I know where
that is and I believe there's an f1 race
there and then I looked where it was on
the map and I was wrong Montenegro
believe it or not it's right on the
Mediterranean Sea and I'll tell you
right now out of all the seas out there
the Mediterranean Sea is the greatest
place I've ever been to in my life and I
bet I bet the beaches of Montenegro are
to die for
especially if you don't wear a mask
thank you everybody
that was a good joke
all right hello from Montenegro which we
now know is it's a crust it's dude east
of Italy with that nipple tanks out not
the food at the high heel
it's south of Bosnia Serbia Croatia in
just north of Macedonia Kosovo Bulgaria
from the best regard to two best cigars
I have a smoke is right on the
Mediterranean Sea Jill bartnik club soda
Kenny ah that right there we were in Tel
Aviv I smoked a part of his series deep
and the first day Cohiba a boost oh and
they were [ __ ] real and I don't need
to look at the band's I don't need to do
any of that [ __ ] you know the second you
light a Cuban
you let a Cuban cigar and it's real
everybody says the same thing after one
hop you just go oh my god that's it
oh my god if your friends lighten it and
he says it first you get chills like
holy [ __ ] these are real right these are
real and it is like oh [ __ ] did I get
the fake one alright hello a Montenegro
don't you think they should change the
name of that country hello bill where my
name is Jesus
aleksander al me KSA and dar and I am
from Montenegro but that reminds me of
my daughter I am Luana from London Nui I
wish you let me read that book I move
with the rock
I like your comedy a lot especially a
podcast you are funny as [ __ ] but your
lovely lady is funnier than you ah come
on
I actually I would never disagree with
that she's hilarious
I am also bold but at least I'm not a
[ __ ] ginger what is a bold but also
bald but also bald but now why don't you
figure that out he wrote bold but I'm
also bought but at least I'm not a
[ __ ] ginger my hatred continues I
hope that you'll come soon in this part
of the world I could say much more about
my English is limited kind regards I've
got to tell you something
everybody breaks balls the way this guy
does that would be one of the most fun
shows I've ever had I think what's
really underrated is the amount of great
[ __ ] talkers out there you know I've
stated the obvious like when I've gone
on the road that like people in Ireland
and Scotland are [ __ ] hilarious
people in Australia for [ __ ]
hilarious
but then underrated right underrated
India some of the biggest wall breakers
I ever met my life [ __ ] hilarious
people then a lot of the other places
like a language barrier so I'm sure that
break in mind well there was in India
too but there's so many telemarketers
over there we were able to communicate
it still kills me that I did a show that
was my opening [ __ ] joke and I forgot
to do it I was so freaked out because I
had to go to the their Embassy to get a
piece of paper I didn't get it I had to
send my passport once again I know I've
told this story before before I went the
NDI to send my passport to San Francisco
to the India's I don't know what what a
consulate [ __ ] the embassy I don't
know what heading it work papers and
then when I went to India I needed to
get a paper that said it was okay I
could that I could leave and the whole
time I was like I liked the [ __ ]
sound of that you know I might prefer
the promoter site I don't worry about it
I'll be [ __ ] fine then we find that
you [ __ ] live here so I ended up
going there and it sucked because I'm
going to be there
six hours and I spent like like four
stressful hours in there in their
government building trying to get this
[ __ ] piece of paper that said I was
gonna leave and the promoters I'm not
worried I'll go in there with you
and then I [ __ ] go and they're like
you can't come in and then I'm in there
I'm chilling with this chick from
Afghanistan and she's like I don't think
I'm getting out of here my god we get
not here either
and then I found out one of those so
beautiful raven hair chick who's replace
the PM one of those Norah Jones type
chicks but not her what else [ __ ] yeah
well she won a Grammy
she had an album and she just went
Grammy she was beautiful had dark hair
played the piano Norah Jones I don't
know all I know it was cheated they told
me my the promoter told me before I went
in there was like yes she was here a
month ago they didn't let her around and
I'm like David let her out my [ __ ]
orange ass out of this [ __ ] country
Oh long story short I have to get a
piece of paper the whole town was doing
my show in the back of my head is like
am I still gonna be here tomorrow
what's that gonna look like you know I
love a cheeseburger and I am in the
wrong goddamn country I'm seeing
straight bottoms I'm trying to [ __ ]
you know think of how I'm gonna survive
over here and my opening joke was gonna
be hey what's up everybody nice to be
here at Mumbai you know the joke or
something like I mean I know I've
already talked to most to you on the
phone by the way I know your name mrs.
Scott that was going to be the opening
joke and I forgot to [ __ ] do it
because I was so freaked out and I ended
up going to the airport right after the
show and then a red-eye flight and I got
there and the gatekeeper guy who's
breaking my balls but there was no
in the airport and I actually got mad at
him in my head I was like you just
[ __ ] yourself what oh yeah I told this
story before but I was never able to do
things they got this great thing in
India where if you ask them a question
like they'll do this thing where they
they just bottle their head they don't
say yes is that yes yes and they don't
go no like I got the piece of paper that
the embassy thing and go okay this just
mean that I'm going to get out of here
hi I'm definitely getting out of here
right and then he goes like just like
and I realized that in that bet in their
country that's that's shrugging that's
that's shrugging your shoulders so I had
to figure that out
so I [ __ ] go to the airport and I'm
like alright I got the paper I got to
get on the plane and the [ __ ] guys
look at the paper and I'm like I'm good
right the guy he starts doing this [ __ ]
I just wanted to grab his [ __ ] head
and just start tilting it like an old TV
set you know maybe actually God blessed
that man let me get on and I did not
feel comfortable until like change
planes to Tel Aviv and I got on the
greatest airline there is that I order
to get the name it's why they still hire
like that kids say still hire beautiful
stewardess miss Singapore Airlines and
people to stewardesses to Arab Emirates
air Emirates oh my god it was like being
on an airplane thirty years ago and he
on the Texans all at the same time it
was the future and the past and the
greatest [ __ ] way ever was amazing
and I used all my miles and we sat up
front and I went in the back first class
you will upstairs we went downstairs
with all these [ __ ] animals we were
upstairs in the privileged area and I
loved every second of it and every
[ __ ] free mmm that I ate I didn't
once think about you people who put your
pant legs on one at a time I don't give
a [ __ ]
I so I go to the back I'm gonna take a
50 not question what this is I'm going
back it up and I go in the back and
there's like a [ __ ] half circle bar
like a full [ __ ] bar that like six
people could sit it on oh my oh my god
so I take the lead like and I came back
and I said that my loving wife is gonna
be here come on back she goes what do we
go I should say where we gonna go I'm
gonna show me the bathroom I go no come
on I want to I want to get you a drink
she goes you can't better just [ __ ]
come with me and I took her to the back
and she saw that semicircle thing and it
next to the semicircle bar they had a
bench seat with this giant [ __ ] I
remember it is one giant seatbelt which
is really creepy because if you didn't
know the person then you got to kind of
share it you know but I don't know it's
a different you know there's different
cultures I don't know what right
so I [ __ ] in that we sat down and I had
two drinks I got a nice [ __ ] buzz
going and I remember we were on our way
to New York I forget what the [ __ ] we
were doing over there and I do remember
we stayed at some really expensive hotel
that I was pissed when I got the bill my
wife what I thought you'd like it cousin
had a chair Best Western as a gym we're
in New York walk over to the subway then
I'm burning enough calories I just go
stay away from the pizza I'm trying to
do is make it nice
I'm sorry
all right I am normally okay I'll clear
up this [ __ ] I want to clear up this
[ __ ]
by the way this is a business video here
jailbroken joking around about those
masks and for some reasons the story
became like I schooled him or you know I
was shutting them down blah blah I
[ __ ] love Joe Rogan it's one of my
great friends in this [ __ ] business I
don't know why they always have to pick
you if you look at us for both laugh and
our asses off we're a couple of [ __ ]
meatheads smoking cigars having a good
time alright so anyways this guy writes
yeah yeah yeah I don't want to read this
to feed the [ __ ] thing I do I
supposed to read the next one the next
one alright Matt do your Billy two-step
you must have seen me dance I could do
that I could dance in a little box you
know it's all about getting on the dance
floor with the woman who she knows how
to dance she [ __ ] dances around you
just do this [ __ ] right yeah I'll pay
hands up here not touching anything not
touching anything ladies dear Billy to
static I'm loving the bill part podcast
thank you last week you mentioned that
the clip that went viral of you and
Rogan wasn't what it seemed to be and
that you had just busted Joe's balls and
making him laugh yeah yesterday Joe had
Jon Stewart on and they talked about
that clip Joe joke we said can you say
you'll wear a mask of Jon jokingly said
that Joe said of course he wears masks
in public then he was just trying to get
you going
none of this seems far-fetched I was
wondering if you could address the
people who tried to co-opt your new
humor to fit there we don't like Joe
Rogan agenda
I saw many tweets saying things like
Bill Byrne helping to cancel Joe Rogan
yeah man that [ __ ] I got to tell you
something right now that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] like all these progressive
people that are literally like Fox News
could learn something from them the way
they edit [ __ ] and present evidence and
all of that type of stuff it's just like
people this there's a big beautiful
world out there and there's room for
everybody and if you're gonna take
somebody out you know what I mean just
[ __ ] do you do diligence
alright you know
this [ __ ] there was nothing to this this
was just us having fun and then you're
pissed about something else and then
you're trying to like you know hey no no
shut the [ __ ] up you're an even older
white guy than enough can you believe
he's stoned so ever this thing has been
and drinking like 30 [ __ ] years
all right yes you're right exactly
anyways all right can I catch the
project that you're doing by the way
fine all right see like how I asked all
right chicken intelligence hey Billy Boy
hey Billy Boy
in June I'm huge all this amazing thing
I was talking about there's all this
[ __ ] about chickens have chickens count
up to 10 they can see more colors than
us so I was saying if you have a bunch
of chickens and you're gonna kill one
you got to make sure you have over 10 so
they don't get why school right but so
just start over again like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 I think everybody's here right they
stop at 10 you have a thousand chickens
who killed 990 you gotta kill 991 before
these stupid chickens figure it out
right in your June 18th podcast you said
you were bothered by eating chickens
even though they have the intelligence
of a two-year-old did I say it was or it
wasn't that word
you said that what reading level would
it take to get you to stop eating a
chicken all right my family has been
raising chickens for generations and let
me give you the other side of the story
everybody gets their feelings as an
owner of chickens of all of all of the
barnyard animals chickens are easily the
stupidest I love it I always heard pigs
you start our here cows are smart too
our horses are smart but they're a
little full of themselves anybody else
they got that nice man you know they
because [ __ ] doesn't stink of all the
barnyard animals chickens aren't easily
the stupidest they are little better
than the lizards raising chickens is a
constant battle to keep these feathered
idiots from killing themselves or each
other people outside I think they really
are just a food source you know what I
mean
they can't run fast they can't [ __ ]
fly and they're delicious
you know God knew what he was doing what
he made what the Pope like people
outside of the poultry business may not
know that's not how he said the poultry
business he's talking shop is just in
case you know you must keep me on my
heels here but one of the most common
causes of chick and death is cannibalism
I'm not making this up oh my god god
bless this guy whether this is even true
or not does it even matter but dude this
is [ __ ] great I'll never feel guilty
again even two toddlers also require
constant attention to make sure they are
safe there is little danger of a poorly
supervised daycare turning into a
Cannibal Holocaust though he uses the
Holocaust word have you ever noticed how
veganism is much more popular among city
people than rural some would say that it
is dude do has to do with education but
I believe it's because people who are
closer to animals have fewer
Asians about how human they are enjoy
your roast chicken the cannibal chickens
would happily join in you join you in
your meal greetings from the sticks
buddy how can you bring it up and not
give me I want to give this stories this
guy master right back I want to hear the
Ed Gein stories of these puppy chickens
eating each other Wow I mean what is
their excuse when the chicken cops show
up and well I mean [ __ ] to eat
chicken he's delicious you on the hunt
when we taste fishing trip this is also
not they described the last when you
just put down there was more all right
classic rock song about Stanley Cup
conspiracy and I promoted the Troubadour
enough I feel like I just sat down just
through the podcaster yes you won again
well I'll cut it in after just all right
so just walking by and the person you're
living with became they standing you
enjoyed this podcast live right now
reporting live and unedited here at the
Troubadour we're raising money to keep
this wonderful venue and some of the
greatest artists of all time from rot
ugly like Richard Pryor's been on this
stage Steve Martin has been on this
stage drops our George Carlin's been on
this stage and then a major drop-off all
the way down the main has been on this
bus we got to save this place come on
this [ __ ] place I've got shit-faced
in here I had bring wait wait [ __ ]
time
this place this place cannot go away I
won't let a woman all right classic rock
song about Stanley Cup conspiracy
palette hey Billy
berroco I hope you didn't struggle with
that last name you hooked on fun but I
did you hooked on phonics reliant old
man how old was this guy that I use
[ __ ] on Phonics they're my age buddy
that was a hacky joke when I started big
fan love on the content you've been
providing us with efforts for family
season for king of Staten Island black
or white at all the podcast appearances
the song 50 mission cap by the Canadian
classic rock band The Tragically Hip
depicts the story of the 1951 Stanley
Cup final between the Toronto Maple
Leafs and the [ __ ] hacks bash and
Ville Haruko scored the winning goal in
game five four months later he takes a
small prop plane to go on a fishing trip
and go back with the buddy the plane
vanishes
the plane was discovered 35 miles off
course 11 years later in 1962 the next
time the Maple Leafs won the Cup 11
years later in 1962 the next time the
maybe least won the Cup all too
coincidental
wait what coincidental thing happened
there the maple leaves weren't in the
cup like every other [ __ ] year one
think that anyway anyways he said it the
way I wrote it the way I say I highly
recommend checking up the tragically hip
their legends up here and never made it
elsewhere because they
a bit too Canadian their songs rock and
their frontman gourd ami has a crazy
life story as well I will definitely
check them out I'm going to look up that
bill Baruch oh wait the plate was
discovered 35 miles off course 11 years
later that with 1951 the next time the
Maple Leafs won the Cup all too
coincidental
well you know what if that band is
Canadian is that [ __ ] analogy I don't
think I'm gonna get a meter I didn't get
that all right how do I tell a friend to
[ __ ] off Mike you want to take this one
all right dear Billy booze ticks
I have not drank in in 19 months all
right
I am better than all of you I'm a 20
year old guide from Montana this place
is making me thirsty I'm a 20 year old
guy from the Netherlands so please
excuse me if my english isn't perfect I
love they always say that and then they
write perfect English I am in a friend
group with seven other guys when I am
friends with only six of them the one
guy I don't like is a complete egomaniac
slash probably the leader of the group
and I don't want to be around it for the
following reasons he always makes
everything about me whenever someone is
telling a personal story you'll
interrupt
way less interesting story about himself
you could say you lost your grandparents
in a horrific car crash and he will
interrupt you by saying his car was
almost hit by a car his cat was almost
hit by a car once that's a great joke
and I [ __ ] it up I'm sorry he always
makes himself out to be the victim of
every single situation whenever
something goes wrong he will always find
a way to talk about how this situation
affected him the most even though a lot
of times this is not the case
this is especially annoying when someone
is opening up about some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that happened in his past which some of
us rarely ever do because of this he is
a [ __ ] dick when it comes to money
Jesus disguises right down the [ __ ]
US duchies are known for being greedy
[ __ ] but this guy gives a whole new
dimension to me whenever he's for it
even the cheapest thing he will demand
his money back immediately
and when he doesn't he will forever
remind you of the one time he bought you
a single drink and how generous he is
for doing so dude the more you're
writing about this guy the less sympathy
I have for you where the [ __ ] is your
self-esteem he should always get it [ __ ]
off in the first two sentences whenever
you buy him something he will never
thank you for it or offer you to pay it
back into a single penny how do I tell
him that I don't want to hang out with
him anymore without starting a big drama
I'm afraid
try to portray me as this evil maniac
who hurts his innocent little heart and
sent my friends up against me I also
don't want to hurt his feelings because
I'm somewhat of a nice guy and I fear oh
yeah who got to the root of the problem
and I figured you may be autistic or
something like that as that would
explain about his antisocial behavior
loved to stand up the podcast Ephesus
family thanks a lot you go [ __ ] yourself
alright we got to give you the order
right there I don't want to hurt his
feeling because I'm somewhat of a nice
guy you're not somewhat of a nice guy
you're too much of a nice guy and I
guarantee his other six friends are also
like that because nobody else would put
up with a guy like that alright so what
you need to do is throw a kick and let
those balls hang down and you need to
tell this guy to [ __ ] off
you're not like what you say your
perception of this story because
everything is alleged everybody until
proven gonna like you you're a cheap
[ __ ] you know I buy you drinks all the
time we never say thanks if you buy you
drink another [ __ ] near the end of it
you always make everything about
yourself
look at you you bottom lip is already
quivering because you think your
feelings are hurt to tell you you're a
[ __ ] and then call them a [ __ ] in
English back to Dutch seven wait what
what do you what do you fear that you're
losing what you need to do is you react
Chui you need to become a stronger
person so you don't because you will
constantly end up in a situation like
this alright a really nice person the
chances of marrying a [ __ ] are often
sharks because [ __ ] marry nice people
that's what I did cuz only nice people
put up with every
alright honoring a psycho how how should
he do it not over the phone
you got to do it face to face how about
the next time somebody's telling the
story and you're interested and he
interrupts and you just just be like oh
you got the [ __ ] up no no better yet
let's hear your story oh my god that's
so much more interesting than I thought
in the war
what other knick-knack did you find at
the back in your closet you boring [ __ ]
hey how about you pick up the check for
once huh then all your other [ __ ]
friends would be staring at the table
because they're gonna be afraid of
confrontation because that's why he
hangs out with you guys all right
honoring a psycho hate their Billy
leader of the new free world this
reminded me of a show you were talking
about where the woman was crazy but they
somehow acted like all their violent
crimes were nothing big I'm a woman and
I've been known and I've known a few
psycho women so I don't discriminate
when it comes to people who need the
chloroform rag that's a bit of noise I
saw my dad showed it to me I think the
article is called overlooked
no more Valerie Solanas radical feminist
who shot any world oh yeah I read about
that I didn't even know that [ __ ]
story
the guy and he ended up dying of his
injuries in job related injuries
injuries related to the shooting like
was it 25 years later here you big in
the art world
Mike Valerie Solanas is best known as
the woman who shot Andy Warhol but to
focus on the shooting is to ignore her
contributions to the feminist movement
including her seminal text scum
manifesto this is from the New York
Times book you know John Wilkes Booth
made an incredible peach cobbler and to
just focus on his assassination of
Abraham Lincoln is to not do this man
justice yeah well I guess I need to be
progressive and understand that this
murderer actually has something to say
this woman who shot a man actually has
some good points to make about the
male-female dynamic can you ever get mad
again with Fox News makes fun of the New
York Times I mean they're not wrong I
mean I think Fox is as bad as a New York
Times on the other side of Jesus Christ
I'll have to read the book how bad you
think white guys were behaving back when
she was around yeah and then I love she
ends up kicking like the most effeminate
like you know it looks like the most
antitoxic I don't know who knows maybe
maybe he was a bully maybe Andy deserve
to be shot
25 years tickets nothing just shows his
white male privilege doctors kept him
alive for 25 years
no need to read on the podcast so why am
i reading this I don't know you get the
bottoms on the end of that the other one
what you got to finish the sheet it's on
that the bottom to start that yeah that
does it New York Times hack New York
Times hack I believe blockbuster now I'm
doing the rest of this yeah sorry
all right no need to read up on the
podcast or heard you talking about how
the Times kicks you off after reading
one article on your podcast with Burt
and Jim Norton yeah whenever I click on
an article that I want to read and I
find out that it's a New York time
related article the thing pops up after
a paragraph and then I click off because
I subscribe to The Boston Globe in the
Boston Herald and I can't remember
passwords and I know Peter why would I
sign it for another newspaper you can
put a after dot-com on any article and
read it for free I shoulda read this on
the [ __ ] now they're gonna know do you
want to shout out John for the 10th lot
without giving out the secret I'll take
the love you're the man all right we've
been out
we've been out Sean asked shout out to
Josh for giving me the New York Times
app I know I've gotta pass it on to
other people I shouldn't even say that
though google it whatever people figure
it out all right that's the pot is that
it yes I want to thank the Troubadour
and I have respect for all the great
rock stars for the most part I did sit
down during all this and I'll take this
didn't we just talk about the venue for
a little bit I cannot believe how small
this [ __ ] stages and I remember
feeling the same way the first time I
went to the Comedy Cellar
during the day I couldn't believe how
small the sandwich and how small the
rooms though because you'd go up there
with so
Electric when the place was full and I
remember the day I had to go down to the
comedy store I mean that the Comedy
Cellar during the day was because of
something for tree stood when he was on
stage that Manny and SP wanted to have a
big comics meeting and Patrice didn't
even show up hilarious and all I
remember that showed up it was me Bobby
Kelly and Dave Attell were the only ones
that showed up with this big comic
meeting if I remember correctly but this
is an absolutely legendary stage I want
to thank everybody here at the
Troubadour for a lot of me to come down
here thank you for all the great shows
that you've done down here and thanking
everybody who's going to buy the poster
or just give anything you can to keep
this amazing venue open it open because
someday you're going to come here
hopefully and see the next great band or
what any of the bands that you always
wanted to see an intimate setting I
absolutely [ __ ] love this place it
would not be la if this place wasn't
still around so if you can I know
everybody's struggling but if you could
help to spend you out it would mean the
world to me like I said I think I'm
gonna start doing one of these down here
every single month maybe I mean yes next
time whatever I can do it's a positive
thing I'm trying to do during this time
with so much everybody screaming and
yelling and at each other's throats
trying to do something positive so
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on you on Thursday
so much for listening thank you to the
Troubadour and they can break my binder
for filling up the VIP with himself and
his giant Hollywood ego
god bless you James Taylor Waylon
Jennings average white band who's I that
is that's a Bette Midler John Denver
Todd Rundgren
Little Feat Sam [ __ ] Kinnison Cheech
and Chong Joan Baez Elton John made his
American debut here if they view in
America I should say pointer sisters
Willie Nelson Miles Davis Van Morrison
Dakin yeah baby wasp Guns & Roses
Metallica Return to Forever who isn't
then I should know that van it was like
a beat that's trigger yeah
I thought 20 Williams was in that that
Jackson Lenny white who's in that band
who's that drummer Lenny who a Herbie
Hancock Kris Kristofferson Jackson
Browne stereo Steve Martin opened for
Richard Pryor that was an actual sugar
can you imagine if you went to that Tom
Petty Cat Stevens Billy Joel Harry
Chapin and the cat jayna cradle Jimmy
Buffett
I love wheel of fortune and what do they
have done you go taupe you go to
Margaritaville like this place if
anything's gonna challenge my sobriety
this is how do you not get [ __ ]
hammered get [ __ ] hammered here man
look at this stuff
this is incredible all right so that
concludes our quick little tour here The
Troubadour thank you guys so much for
watching
you go to the Troubadour website to
donate I have an autographed poster and
I know everybody out there struggling
but if you got a couple extra bucks and
you could send it this way this is such
a legendary place and spend just such a
wonderful venue for so many incredible
artists
throughout the decades and it's a huge
part of Los Angeles and
I don't want to see it go so if you can
help me out and help them out it would
be awesome thank you so much and thank
you for listening
you